[Music]
foreign
did you know that there are many Krakens
in movies and shows including the live
action flicks and also animated ones and
so here in this video we will showcase
10 of these sea monster versions so
let's get into it
number one the Pirates of the Caribbean
Kraken this sea monster filled by
Mariners for centuries resembles a giant
squid with tentacles as long as 10 ships
capable of capsizing vessels
effortlessly the creature under Davey
Jones command brought souls to join his
crew on the Flying Dutchman forever
cursed to serve its huge suckers were
powerful enough to rip the flesh from a
sailor's face the Kraken had squid-like
features with a mantle and long powerful
tentacles
number two the Kraken from The Clash of
the Titans of 1981. so in the 1981 movie
the Kraken plays a significant role as
the pet of Poseidon sent by Zeus to
punish Argos for the king's actions
Perseus defeats the Kraken by using
Medusa's head turning it into stone and
causing it to crumble into the ocean the
creature is portrayed as a massive green
gray bees with a sea Serpent's lower
body with four arms and a merman-like
face surrounded by Thrills stop-motion
photography was used to create the
creature's effects
number three the Kraken from The Clash
of the Titans remake in the 2010 remake
the Kraken is an adversary of Perseus
created by Hades to slay the Titans Zeus
forced the Hades to lock it away but it
is eventually released on Argus Perseus
defeats the Kraken using the same way by
Medusa's head turning it into stone this
Kraken is different in design though
being 400 feet tall white grain overall
coloration with four massive crap like
limbs legs numerous tentacles two arms
and a humanoid head with a mouth full of
sharp teeth
number four the Kraken from Skull Island
series The Skull Island animated series
introduces an enigmatic and formidable
Titan which is also sadistic which is
known as the Kraken combining features
from various animals the creature's
dominant form consists of a light blue
octopus-like body with multiple suction
cup covered tentacles smaller red
tentacles and massive chitinus clawed
full limbs it's immense bulbous head
showcases two sets of glowing orange
eyes partially covered antenna with blue
fuzz and also gills and a formidable
bird-like bee containing sharp teeth
number five the Kraken from Hotel
Transylvania in Hotel Transylvania 3 the
Kraken is a character scene in the ocean
he has a massive bluish purple sea
creature with a large mouth filled with
long sharp teeth and big black eyes has
numerous tentacles were even larger than
the ship called the Legacy despite his
looks the Kraken is depicted as a
Charming friendly and helpful creature
he enjoys entertaining the passengers by
singing the song it's party time and
performing it for their enjoyment
number six the Kraken from tentacles of
the deep also known as the deadly water
this is a 2006 natural horror B movie
The Story follows a marine biologist and
a sailor teaming up to search for lost
Trojan Treasures they must face off
against a giant squid the Kraken that
had killed the sailor's parents before
when he was a child and also fighting a
treasure hunting mobster with selfish
intentions unfortunately the film
received mostly negative reviews from
critics due to the lack of scenes
featuring the creature
number 7 the Kraken from 20 000 Leagues
Under the Sea in the movie The Nautilus
encounters a monster called the Kraken
Nemo tries to ward off the creature
using an electric discharge but this
proves ineffective to protect the
submarine called the Nautilus Nemo its
Captain must confront the Monstrous quit
on a stormy surface during an intense
battle Nemo gets ensnared by one of the
Squid's tentacles but Ned a friend of
his who had managed to free himself
jumps to Nemo's rescue and saves them by
slaying the creature number eight the
Kraken from Cabin in the Woods this
creature was seen only slightly in the
movie this is one of the monsters kept
in the facility in the movie it appears
during the system Purge towards the end
of the film The Creature is an enormous
sea monster with multiple limbs
resembling a giant octopus its long
suction tentacles are visible in the
movie the rest of its body and face
remain unseen despite being aquatic the
Kraken can move on dry ground it is
extremely dangerous possessing
tremendous strength and speed in its
attacks number nine the Kraken from
Atlantis Milo Returns the Kraken double
k a sea monster is the main antagonist
in the movie Atlantis Milo returns it
attacks ships and steel supplies for a
fishing Village in a deal made with
their magistrate called Edgar vulgar
Milo and his friends defeat the kraken
with missiles ending its reign of terror
and causing vulgar's demise The Village
which had been suffering since the
creature's presence scaring away their
fish and sunlight is now in good hands
and number 10 the Kraken from Ruby
Gilman the teenage Kraken so this is a
2023 animated action comedy produced by
Dreamworks Animation the movie follows
Ruby Gilman a shy but kind 15 year old
girl eager to fit in in an Oceanside
High School however her life takes a
turn when she Ventures into the ocean
breaking her mother's Rule and she
discovers that she is a descendant of
battle hardened Krakens destined to
protect the land and sea from evil
mermaids Ruby also learns that she is
destined to inherit the throne from her
commanding grandmother the warrior Queen
of the Seven Seas called Fonda
so those are the 10 Krakens from movies
and TV shows anyway I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos right
here on this channel till the next one
take care fam